this is Earth
this is where you live and this is where
you live in your neighborhood the solar
system
[Applause]
here's the distance between the Earth
and the moon doesn't look too far does
it think again at their farthest point
the earth and the moon are two hundred
and fifty two thousand eighty eight
miles away inside that distance you
could fit every planet in our entire
solar system but let's talk about
planets the Great Red Spot on Jupiter
that's about two times as big as Earth
and Saturn is about nine times wider
than Earth Saturn's rings are so large
that a few of the fragments within them
are as large as mountains but that's
nothing compared to our Sun just
remember this is Earth and this is Earth
from the moon this is Earth from Mars
here's Earth from just behind Saturn's
rings and here's Earth from just beyond
Neptune four billion miles away but a
billion is a big number so let's put
that in perspective one million seconds
equals about eleven and a half days
whereas 1 billion seconds equals over 31
years let's step back a bit here's the
size of Earth compared with the size of
our Sun terrifying right
and here's that exact same Sun from the
surface of Mars as Carl Sagan once mused
the total number of stars in the
universe is larger than all the grains
of sand on all the beaches of the planet
Earth and there are some stars out there
that are much much bigger than our
little wimpy Sun the biggest star we
know of V Y Canis Majoris is about 2,000
times the diameter of our Sun
but none of those compares to the size
of a galaxy in fact if you shrink the
size of our solar system down to the
size of a quarter and tranq the Milky
Way galaxy down using the same scale the
diameter of the Milky Way will be
roughly the size of the United States
that's because the Milky Way galaxy is
huge
it's diameters about 100,000 light-years
wide which when converted to miles is
about 621 quadrillion 371 trillion 192
billion 237 million three hundred thirty
three thousand eight hundred ninety
miles inside of all that is you you live
in this tiny tiny portion of the Milky
Way but even still our galaxy is a
little runt compared with some others
NGC 674 for a spiral galaxy similar to
our own is twice as wide as the Milky
Way stretching over two hundred thousand
light-years across it is a massive but
let's think bigger in this picture alone
taken by the Hubble telescope there are
thousands and thousands of galaxies each
containing millions or billions of stars
with their own planets
some of the objects seen here may have
formed as many as 11 billion years ago
just three billion years after the Big
Bang
[Music]
this period of time is considered one of
the busiest star-forming periods
and just keep this in mind that's a
picture of a very small small part of
the universe
so if you ever feeling upset about your
favorite show being canceled or the fact
that they play Christmas music way too
early just remember this is your home
earth
[Applause]
[Music]